Hey, everybody. Hope you're doing well in this chapter
I will be teaching you the most mechanical gold training strategy. So
Previously, I made a video on gold and it was only for the people who could trade the Asian session, right?
But this one is gonna work in London session and I've been getting a lot of requests
So this chapter of this course is gonna explain each and everything about the strategy
So make sure you watch till the end so you don't miss anything. Now my goal always has been to
You simplify trading. All right, I don't want you guys to be looking for daily buyers and doing these top-down analysis
Yes, of course they they have a little bit of advantage over mechanical strategies
But this strategy that about to teach you right now
Bro, trust me. It works every single day like there is no day that it won't work
Alright, so what exactly is the strategy, right? So we know that the
London session starts at 3 a.m. New York time. All right, so let's assume that this is the
London session open right now
All you have to do is go to the 15 minute time frame
right and
The very first forever you got that forms during the London session. So this is the London open
You are basically waiting for price to create some form of a fair valley gap the very first
Fair valley gap that forms during the London session. Remember that
So let's assume that we have this fair valley gap formed around here
All right, so all I'm actually waiting for is to price for the price to inverse it and
What I mean by this is I want the price
to close below it
Okay, so the entire strategy is basically how this is how it goes. So during London
Mark out
The first a fidget that forms and then wait for it to get in first
All right, so remember this now
All you are waiting for to do from here onwards when the fair valley gap gets
Inversed is you are taking your entry on the retest you're going for one to two and
you are targeting some form of liquidity, right and
Basically you're putting your stop above the bodies. So this is your entry. So let's suppose that this is weak
Right. So this part of this price is the wake, but then over here are the bodies
So you're gonna put your stop here not above the wick but above the bodies
Literally, this is literally it's gonna work every single day guys. All right now
It works for forex as well, but there are some other methods for it
I'm gonna teach that in the upcoming chapters
But for now, this is the best goal strategy for the London session, right and similarly if you look at it here
You know, we have this London open here at three, right?
And I'm gonna give you guys some examples. So don't worry. I'm gonna explain all of the other things as well
You can see that we have the fresh privilege gap that forms right the very first. All right, you have to put entire focus on that
fair valley gap and
Then you can see that whenever price
Inverses it is when you take your entry from the retest
All right, so what is a high probability setup in this for this strategy, right?
so
Let's assume that price created some form of liquidity before going into London open and
We create a fair valley gap the very first fair valley gap that forms during the London session. All right
And you have these equal highs liquidity level somewhere around here. Now. This is the high probability
Setup so when price inverses that fresh valley gap you can actually take you into your own the retest or on the body closure
So if the body closes slightly above it, then you can take your entry
straight away
but if it's gone way far up ahead and
You know, you think that your stop was gonna be big then you take your entry from the retest put your stop below the bodies
And then you can target easily target these equal highs over here
now, what if the
liquidity is swept before you get your entry, right and
This is what's gonna make the setup low probability because we have already reached our target
But rest assured even if the liquidity is swept there might be some high time from liquidity resting above here
That the price will take out all you need to do is just look for the very first fair valley gap that forms during the London session
And then you're waiting for it to get in versed and then you're looking to take your entry from the retest or
Or or or you know, just entering straight away now
Do you think to note is that if there is some form of news, right?
You just want to avoid that setup and wait till 15 minutes pass right after news
You do not want to trade before news because what's gonna happen is price is gonna do something like this, right?
It's gonna just mess up everything. So you want to avoid the high impact news
So by now this should be clean perfectly clean, right?
now there is another way to to improve the windward and that is by marking some form of high time from PDRA and
Price dips into that PDRA and then it reverses the first really gap that prompt, right?
Or it's simply just swept some form of liquidity here, right?
And once it's swept sweeps that and inverses the very first fair valley gap of the London session
Then you can take your entry this setup is insanely powerful guys, and I'm gonna give you guys some examples now
And you are going to thank me before I move to the examples if you're watching this on YouTube
I want to let you know that my new course is coming out very soon
So if you want free access to my course, you have to enroll into my current course right now
Otherwise if you don't do it and the new course releases is gonna be priced at a different level
But now if you enroll into my current course, you can actually get the entire access to my discord where I have the course videos
We're absolutely free. So let's move on to the examples now
All right guys
So here is example one and we're waiting for the London Open and at 3 a.m. We have the London Open
so we now we are waiting for a fair valley gap formation and
Straight away. What do we have we have a fairly gap that formed around here? So now we're waiting for price to inverse it
Right and you can see we also set some form of liquidity here
so now we're waiting for price to inverse and
Right away. We have the inversion. So I'm gonna take my entry on the retest. I'm gonna put my stop right below these bodies
not below the wake but below the body and
Probably we can target one to two here
And I can leave some runners till here, but I usually go for one to two and that's it
So you can see we get our entry on the retest
And the take profit level was hit and then price, you know, eventually it went up to that
liquidity level and it took it out
Although I would always go for one to two and you can see how price just went up ahead and reacted from this auto block here
Push down below. Well, if you had your stop below the wake then
Maybe you could have but you would still be close at break even so it's best to always take your profit at one to two
Let me give you guys some more examples. All right guys. So here is example two and this is the london open
so I'm waiting for a fairly gap formation
and
Just around here we have the very first fairly gap of the london session. So the london session is from 3am to 7am, right?
So I'm waiting for price to inverse it
And right away, but do we have we have inverse it and we have these equal highs resting around this area
And we have also swept some form of liquidity here. So
I'm just gonna long here put my stop below the body here
And I can go for one to two. I don't care. All right. I'm just gonna go break even at one to one. So I'm risk-free
So
Let's zoom what happened here
You can see that at this point I would go break even right but since one to one. Yeah, so I'm just gonna hold till one to two
And eventually it goes up ahead and takes out
This high over here as well
So you can see how we inverse the very first fairly gap and we had these liquidity resting above here
It is not necessary these two steps, right the liquidity sweep and the
The resting liquidity is not necessary, but
It's gonna improve the win rate always always gonna always improve the win rate
But if you want to keep things as mechanical as possible
Just wait for the first fairly gap to get inverse and take your entry bro. It's
It's really really not that hot and if I go just around here you can see
that
We have this fairly gap the very first probably gap that formed during the london
And notice what happened we had
This liquidity level resting around here, right?
And we swept this liquidity here and then we
Inversed the fairly gap the first fairly gap of the london session
short position right here stop right above the bodies here and
A beautiful one to two risk to reward
Right away. So two examples in one clip. Let me give you guys some more examples
All right guys. So here is another example and we have the london open here. So I'm waiting for a fairly gap formation
And we do have it around here. So notice two things now we have swept
This liquidity these relative equal highs over here
Right
We also swept this high over here. That's perfect and we have these equal lows resting around this level
So what does this directly tell you that we're going to inverse it and then we're going to push down like crazily
All right
So right away. What do we have? We have an inversion entry on the retest stops above the bodies of the highest wick
So this is the highest wick
The bodies. All right, because if price goes here
There's 99 percent chance gonna take out this level. So just don't bother
And one to two. So let's see how this plays out
We get our retest
And we push down and the take profit was hit notice how the bodies were respected inside this inversion
All right, this is all algorithm bro. Like it's it's it's it's
Insane how well this shit works
All right. So over here
You can see bro. It just happens every single day
So this is the London session start right no further gap no further gap and then
Out of nowhere. We have a fairly gap. We sweep the liquidity here, right
And we have this insane amount of liquidity resting here
Right and you can just see how well
It works. So
inversion
Entry on the retest or actually I would enter here because it's just way close way too close
And my stop you can see this is the highest wick some I would put it somewhere around here
And wow
Insane guys, it's just
It's incredible how well it works. All right
All right guys. So here is the last example and this is the London open. So we're waiting for a fairly gap formation
And right away
We have the very first fairly gap that forms during the London session and over here
You can see we have equal highs and those were swept as well
And then we have this London sorry Asian low as I withdraw on liquidity
And you can also see we tapped into this volume imbalance here
So there are just so many confluences telling you to shot this bro
And then we have the inversion here, right and on the retest
You can see
Straight away
Stopped right above the bodies, but since the wick is not that big. I can actually put it here. It's no problem. All right
I would go for one to two
But let's see how this plays out. So we got our entry
And price just melted
All right. So the key thing to note here is guys
If if you really want this model to work every single way number one
Look
For liquidity sweep
All right
This is key because you know, it's not like
Necessary, but as I showed I showed you so many examples where price strips some form of significant liquidity equal highs equal lows
And then the push is insane
Right. So look for liquidity sweep, right?
And or price goes into some form of key level here and then
Clear draw on liquidity, right? You have clear draw on liquidity in this example. We had this
Lr Lr something and I don't want to use complicated words. It's just liquidity bro. All right, trendline liquidity. What I want to call it
Clear draw liquidity and then you are waiting for the first
inversion of
First for the furbity gap that forms in london
This is literally
Your bread and butter guys like it works so well that you have no idea
All right. Now some days what's going to happen is
So let me just show you here. Okay
Actually, we inverse this here as well. This was a tiny little furbity gap and you can see that we formed it at three, right?
so
Sometimes the furbity gap is going to format exactly at three. So the the second candle
If it's at three then it's acceptable. However, if the second candle is at two forty five
So furbity gap is off three candles, right? One two three. Now. I want the second candle
To be at three am exact. This should be the one
All right
If it doesn't form here, then I'm looking for another furbity gap to form
But since what people would do is they would consider this
As the first furbity gap and I do not want to see this. All right
Why? Because the second candle formed at two forty five. So this is not the furbity gap that formed in the london. However
This one right here
It formed right during london
So
Yeah guys um
This is practically the entire model and you can see that we had this inverse furbity gap here as well
And price is dip below it bro. Uh, let me show you guys a losing
Trade hopefully I can find it
So we inverse the first furbity gap here
Oh my god, bro. I'm just gonna end the video when I find a losing
The losing trade. This is the first furbity gap
Oh my god inverse and it just went up
There's there is there any furbity gap
There's no furbity gap bro
So you just simply skip the day
This is the first furbity gap body didn't close no inversion
Dude, there's not a single losing trade bro
Come on. I gotta find one losing trade bro. Oh my god. There's another inverse. Look at it. Look at it
Oh my god. This this isn't saying please. Please. Please. I need to find a losing trade
Otherwise, I won't be able to end the video
Okay, this is some form of a losing. I don't know. I just I just want a losing trade, bro
Even though it was way late in the london and this is the first furbity gap that formed
No, this is not a this is not a good losing trade. I want to see a better losing trade
Oh my god
Wow, dude dude dude guys guys. I'm telling you
Okay, this shit is insane. Look at this. All right
There's no losing trade bro. Hopefully here hopefully hopefully hopefully hopefully
Ah
All right, so you might have noticed one thing if the furbity gap forms way too late
So in the sixth hour so from six sam to seven it becomes lower probability
Even though we had a beautiful reaction from here and we took out
The liquidity
Anyways, I want to see a losing trade guys. I'm losing my mind over here. Come on. Give me a losing trade
This is the first furbity gap that forms in the london
We sweep liquidity
And we take out this level. This is insanity
Hopefully here hopefully we here have a losing trade
first inverse
Oh my god
Guys, I think the video is never going to end
There's no furbity gap here actually hopefully guys guys I finally found a losing trade
No, no freaking with this this is not a furbity gap
Oh my god. I'm losing my mind. I'm losing my mind guys. There's no furbity gap here
Okay, finally bro finally
God damn it
And the reason why we lost this trade was we didn't sweep this significant liquidity over here
All right guys, this is gonna be the end
We finally found the losing trade. I hope you guys leave a subscribe and if you're watching it into this code
I hope you guys enjoyed watching this and learn something from it. I'll see you guys in the next chapter